call me dude Z hold on dude yeah hold on
a second dude
hold on dude oh [__] okay go on go on
wait no hold on a second you really want
to take a [__] dude yeah kale you can't
say uh if I may as Hulk Hogan I won't
I'm not what that you that cancels out
your if I may
real
let me tell you something real pods
rules yeah [__] yeah I will never if I
may in Hulk Hogan's voice again per your
request oh wow okay and I will always
stop on your if I may while I'm doing
Hulk Hogan okay but not other
impersonations because those are the
rules yeah you can use a little balls in
your own argument it's macho man trying
to [__] here's my impersonation I'll
rise to the top yeah
laughs